my name's Richard I'd say I'm the
director here enters recruitment and as
a business we specialize in place and
graduates and trainings into sales roles
throughout the UK
yes what major reason for us was we were
posting quite a bit on LinkedIn before
the program but our content was probably
lacking a bit of direction I felt at
times we probably just paused him for
the sake of posting without getting a
real return on it so I brought you in
here she was it gives them a more
strategy you know potentially some more
ideas as well and ultimately in C we can
convert some of that attention into a
return on investment
I think probably what we've achieved is
is better content first and foremost and
more relevant to the people we're trying
to target and that's probably been
reflected in the engagement piece we've
seen a certain likes and comments which
is benefited does this business because
we've got to convert some of those into
new candidates and you client
relationships
I think the major reason for me is that
it gets consultants thinking so you know
consultants probably where now with
modern age of LinkedIn recruitment they
do have to put content on LinkedIn what
the program does is it gets them to
think about what content that we produce
who they're actually marking themselves
at and actually gives them a plan and
some strategy about how to execute it so
that's the main value we've taken away
from it you know we have benefit as well
monetary wise you know we should
register a lot you can dance as a result
we've lost some new clients for us as
well so there'd be the major reasons I
recommending the program